Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello and welcome to The Rest Is History. Now we're in the middle of our great World Cup marathon, a podcast for every country that's qualified for the finals in Qatar. All kinds of weird and wonderful stories. And Tom, I believe we are now venturing to the sands of Saudi Arabia. Is that right? We are. We're actually venturing to Mecca, the holiest place in the holiest city in Islam,
感谢收听《历史其余部分》。要想收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们广受欢迎的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史其余部分》。现在我们正处于伟大的世界杯马拉松的中期，这是一档为所有晋级卡塔尔决赛圈的国家准备的播客。各种稀奇古怪、精彩绝伦的故事。汤姆，我相信我们现在正在前往沙特阿拉伯的沙海。对吗？是的。我们实际上正前往麦加，伊斯兰教最圣洁的圣地、最圣洁的城市，
and the holiest mosque in Mecca, the Majid al-Haram, the inviolable mosque, and the holiest spot within that mosque, which is the Kaaba. So that is the theme of today's episode. Brave choice, Tom. Well, it's the most famous structure within the limits of Saudi Arabia. It's the most famous structure within global Islam. And for Muslims, probably the single most holy structure in the whole world basically for two reasons um the first is that it it constitutes the qibla which is the direction that muslims um turn to when they pray so that's what they're praying to yeah um and the second is that it's the great object of muslim pilgrimage so you know you you can go anytime, but there is a particular time.
以及麦加最圣洁的清真寺——禁寺（Masjid al-Haram），即不可侵犯的清真寺，还有该清真寺内最圣洁的地点，也就是克尔白。这就是今天节目的主题。勇敢的选择，汤姆。嗯，这是沙特阿拉伯境内最著名的建筑。它是全球伊斯兰教中最著名的建筑。对穆斯林来说，它可能是整个世界上最神圣的单一建筑，基本上出于两个原因。嗯，第一个原因是它构成了“基卜拉”（qibla），也就是穆斯林祈祷时面向的方向，所以那是他们祈祷的指向，是的。嗯，第二个原因是它是穆斯林朝觐的伟大对象，所以你知道，你随时都可以去，但有一个特定的时间。
So it's a kind of, I think it's five, six day period in the last month of the Muslim calendar, which moves around because it's a lunar calendar. So you can't absolutely pin it down. And this is the Hajj, very famous pilgrimage. And it is one of the five pillars of Islam. So one of the things that's absolutely incumbent on Muslims, if they possibly can, is at least once in their lives to undertake the pilgrimage to Mecca and specifically to the Kaaba. And so in non-COVID periods, you get huge numbers. Yeah, millions of people. Millions. I think in 2012, it was over 3 million, the Saudi authorities said.
所以这大约是……我认为是穆斯林历法最后一个月的五到六天时间，这个时间会变动，因为它是阴历。所以你无法完全确定具体日期。这就是朝觐，非常著名的朝觐。它是伊斯兰教的五功之一。因此，穆斯林如果可能的话，绝对必须履行的义务之一，就是在他们一生中至少进行一次前往麦加、特别是前往克尔白的朝觐。因此，在没有新冠疫情的时期，会有大量的人前往。是的，数以百万计的人。数百万。我想在2012年，沙特官方称有300多万人。
So it's a huge, huge thing. And so, Tom, just before you go into the history and you explain, because I've always been fascinated by what's in the Kaaba, and I'm hoping you're going to tell me but just for people who don't know so i'm looking at a picture of it right now and you have the mosque i mean you often see it packed with people all wearing white don't you you have the mosque and it's now nowadays it's surrounded by hotels and places where the pilgrims stay and then in the center it's a large black cube yeah and it derives from the arabic word from the root meaning cube so it's carba cube um it's built of stone it's covered
所以这是一件规模极其宏大、极其重要的事情。那么，汤姆，在你讲述历史并进行解释之前——因为我一直对克尔白里面有什么很着迷，我希望你能告诉我——不过，对于那些不太了解的人来说，我现在正在看一张它的照片，你看到了清真寺，我的意思是，你经常看到它挤满了人，全都穿着白衣，对吧？你看到了清真寺，如今它周围环绕着酒店和朝圣者居住的地方，然后在正中间，是一个巨大的黑色立方体。是的，它源自阿拉伯语单词，其词根意思是“立方体”，所以卡尔巴（Kaaba）就是立方体。嗯，它是用石头建造的，覆盖着
with uh a great black silk covering called the kizwa which is embroidered with with gold um and in the eastern corner of of the uh of the carver you have a mysterious black stone and this black stone is very important because it's the key for the ritual that's called the toaf and what you do as a pilgrim you're supposed to is you're supposed to go and kiss or touch the the black stone but generally this isn't possible because there are so many pilgrims there right um but you know that's the ideal. And then you go round the Kaaba in a kind of anti-clockwise motion. And as you do it, you recite the Bismillah, which is, in the name of God, the most gracious, the most merciful, and the Takbir, which is Allahu Akbar. God is the greatest God.
一块巨大的黑色丝绸覆盖物，被称为“基斯瓦”（Kizwa），上面绣有金线。在卡尔巴的东角，有一个神秘的黑石。这块黑石非常重要，因为它是被称为“塔瓦夫”（Tawaf）的仪式关键所在。作为朝圣者，你应该去做的事情是去亲吻或触摸黑石，但通常由于那里有太多的朝圣者，这是不可能做到的，对吧？不过，你知道，那是理想状态。然后你以逆时针的方向绕着克尔白走。当你这样做时，你背诵“太斯米”（Bismillah），也就是“奉至仁至慈的真主之名”，以及“戴克比尔”（Takbir），即“真主至大”（Allahu Akbar）。真主是至高无上的真主。
And I think that I can only imagine that to be a part of that, I mean, it must be an extraordinary, extraordinary experience. Because if you've ever seen it, I mean, the sense of the vastness of it, the sense of being part of a kind of single community must be completely overwhelming. And very few or indeed no non-Muslims living today have presumably ever seen it because it's prohibited to enter the Holy See. It is prohibited. Yeah, it is prohibited. Yeah. Although people in the past, I think I'm right in saying, disguised themselves and did see it. Am I right?
我只能想象，成为其中的一部分……我的意思是，那一定是一次非同寻常、无与伦比的体验。因为如果你曾见过它，那种浩瀚无垠的感觉，那种成为某种单一社群一部分的感觉，一定让人感到完全被压倒。而且今天活着的极少数、甚至根本没有非穆斯林亲眼见过它，因为禁止进入圣地。这是禁止的。是的，这是禁止的。是的。尽管过去有人——我想我没记错的话——伪装自己并亲眼看过。我没记错吧？
Yes. So Richard Burton is the notorious one who, explorer, who went. There is a, you know, the obvious question then is well why what's why are they going why does the carver have this this central role within islam and this is where you have the sense that history as it would be understood say by a secular non-muslim and history as it has traditionally been understood uh within the kind of you know the the vast matrix of Islamic belief and faith and the way that the world is interpreted. They don't necessarily map onto one another. But I think it's impossible to understand the significance that the Kaaba has. Even if you're not a Muslim,
是的。所以理查德·伯顿是那个著名的探险家，他去过那里。有一个显然的问题，那就是为什么——卡巴圣石在伊斯兰教中为什么有这样一个核心角色？在这里，你会有一种感觉：世俗的非穆斯林所理解的历史，与传统上在伊斯兰信仰和信念的宏大矩阵内以及世界被解释的方式中所理解的历史，并不一定完全吻合。但我觉得，无论你是不是穆斯林，要想理解卡巴圣石的重要性都是不可能的——
you look at the history as it has traditionally been understood by Muslims to explain its, dare I say, sacral significance. Because if you can't call the Kaaba sacral, then you can't really call anything sacral. Oh, Tom, this is your dream podcast. It absolutely is. So tell me, are you going to tell us first what Muslims believe the Kaaba to be? And then are you going to sort of deconstruct it? Is that your plan? Well, I'm going to give you what Muslims, what the traditional account is of the history of the Kaaba.
哪怕你不是穆斯林，你也会去看看穆斯林传统上所理解的历史，来解释它那可以说是神圣的重要性。因为如果不能称卡巴为神圣的，那你真的就不能称任何东西为神圣的。哦，汤姆，这绝对是你梦想中的播客。完全是这样。那么告诉我，你会先告诉我们穆斯林认为卡巴是什么吗？然后你会去解构它吗？这是你的计划吗？好吧，我要讲的是穆斯林对卡巴历史的传统说法是什么。
And then perhaps we can discuss what you make of it if you're not a Muslim. Entirely understanding that, you know, for a Muslim, it obviously has a different signification if you're not a Muslim. So for Muslims, the answer to what the Kaaba is, is in the Quran, which is what you'd expect. The Quran, the revelations of God given to Muhammad, he is the prophet who delivers these
然后也许我们可以讨论一下，如果你不是穆斯林，你会怎么看待它。完全可以理解的是，对穆斯林来说，如果你不是穆斯林，它显然有着不同的意义。所以对穆斯林来说，卡巴是什么的答案就在《古兰经》里，这也是你所料想的。《古兰经》是真主降示给穆罕默德的启示，他就是传达这些启示的先知——
revelations. And Muslim scholars have identified 18 references to the Kaaba in the Quran. And there are two mentions of the Kaaba itself, but Muslim scholars have argued that it's referred to in a variety of other ways as well. So it might be called the house, it might be called the sacred house, it might be called the ancient house. And there's one particular crucial section. And I will quote, surely the first house laid down for the people was indeed that at baka a blessed house and a guidance for the worlds in it are clear signs the standing place of abraham whoever enters it is secure i.e because um you can't have any bloodshed permitted in the in the area it's it's it's a sacred area right um pilgrimage to the house is an obligation on the people
穆斯林学者在《古兰经》中找出了18处提到卡巴的地方。其中有两次直接提到了卡巴本身，但穆斯林学者认为，它还以各种其他方式被提及。所以它可能被称为房屋，可能被称为圣房，也可能被称为古房。这里有一个特别关键的部分。我引用一下：“为世人创设的第一所房子，确是在麦加的那所吉祥的房子，是全世界的向导。其中有明证，即易卜拉欣的立足处；谁进入它，谁就安全。”也就是说，因为你在该地区不允许有任何流血事件，这是一个神圣的区域，对吧？……去那所房子朝觐是人们对真主所承担的义务，只要有能力前往的人皆当如此。
to god for anyone who is able to make a way to it. So that's where you get the idea of this being one of the pillars of Islam and why people who can do it, people who are healthy enough, have to do it. Obviously, that raises some questions. So it's described as being at Baka, not Mecca not mecca or mecca and mecca is mentioned later in the quran um so it's not immediately obvious that they're the same and scholars have muslim scholars have recognized this and so there is a tradition that says that baka is um the the sacred site that surrounds the kaba and mecca is the city itself right um and it's And in the Quran, it's described also as the mother of cities, as the peaceful city. These are places that are also mentioned in the Quran. So, Tom, just to pause for a second to locate us for people who aren't massively familiar with the early history of Islam.
所以，这就是为什么它被视为伊斯兰教的支柱之一，以及为什么有能力的人、身体健康的人必须去做的原因。显然，这引发了一些问题。所以它被描述为在巴卡（Baka），而不是麦加（Mecca）——不是麦加或麦加，而且麦加后来才在《古兰经》中被提到——所以它并不那么显而易见地是同一个地方，穆斯林学者也意识到了这一点，因此有一个传统说，巴卡是环绕卡巴的圣地，而麦加则是城市本身，对吧？……而且在《古兰经》中，它也被描述为众城之母、和平之城。这些也是《古兰经》中提到的地方。所以，汤姆，暂停一下，为那些对伊斯兰教早期历史不太熟悉的人定位一下。
We're in what? The early 7th century? Yeah. So, Muhammad had his revelations, I think, when he was 40 years old. The first one, but they come throughout his life. Yeah. Meanwhile, the Eastern Romans and the Persians are kind of knocking seven bells out of each other to the north. And Muhammad is having his revelations in his cave.
我们在什么时候？7世纪初吗？是的。所以，穆罕默德得到启示时，我想他大约40岁。第一次启示，但这些启示贯穿了他的一生。是的。与此同时，北部的东罗马人和波斯人正在互相大打出手。而穆罕默德则在他的山洞里接受启示。
That's the traditional account. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah. So that's the historical background. So Mecca and Baca, are they the same? Are they kind of, you know, they both refer to Mecca. So that's one assumption. The other is in that passage is why Abraham?
那是传统的说法。是的，绝对是。所以这就是历史背景。那么麦加和巴卡是同一个地方吗？它们是不是……你知道的，它们都指代麦加？所以这是一个假设。另一个假设是，在那段经文中，为什么是易卜拉欣？
So Abraham is a biblical prophet. He appears in the Old Testament. He is the ancestor through Isaac of the Jews. And according to Muslim tradition, through his other son, Ishmael, by a concubine called Hagar. He's the ancestor of the Arabs. And so he's in that, you have this thing, the place of Abraham, that he is responsible in some way for the Kaaba. And he appears again and again throughout the Quran. He's a very significant figure within it and within the history that is as traditionally told about the Kaaba. But the thing that people will probably have picked up is that the Quran, I mean, it doesn't give you a kind of straight narrative
所以易卜拉欣是一位圣经先知。他出现在《旧约》中。他是犹太人通过伊萨克的祖先。根据穆斯林的传统，通过他的另一个儿子、由一个名叫哈芝的妾所生的伊斯梅尔，他是阿拉伯人的祖先。所以他就在那里，你有这样一样东西——易卜拉欣的地方，他在某种程度上对卡巴负有责任。他在《古兰经》中一次又一次地出现。他在其中以及在传统上关于卡巴的历史中是一个非常重要的形象。但人们可能会注意到的是，吉兰经——我的意思是，它并没有给你一个关于这方面的直接叙述——
about this. The verses are quite elliptical. They're quite cryptic. They're quite enigmatic. And adding to the complication in terms of trying to make sense of this as history is the fact that there basically aren't any other references to the Kaaba or indeed Mecca prior to the Quran. And so the challenge of constructing its history is incredibly complex. Right. its history is incredibly complex. And a lot of what Muslim tradition says doesn't come from the Quran, but it comes from kind of elaborations about the Quran or various traditions that have emerged over the course of the decades and centuries that follow the time of Muhammad. So what I will do now is give you a kind of a synopsis of what Muslim tradition, and there are various variants of this but i'll give
这些经文相当隐晦。它们相当神秘，相当含蓄。为了将其作为历史来理解，更加复杂的是，事实上，除了《古兰经》之外，基本上没有任何其他关于卡巴或麦加的提及。因此，构建其历史的挑战是极其复杂的。对吧？它的历史是极其复杂的。穆斯林传统的很多内容并非来自《古兰经》，而是来自对《古兰经》的阐释，或者是随着穆罕默德时代之后的几十年和几个世纪的发展而出现的各种传统。所以接下来我要做的是，给你一个穆斯林传统的概述——这有各种变体，但我会给你——
you the kind of the the most orthodox tradition the standard tradition what it says about why the carver is as significant as it is so it's in the chronicles that it's as well as the carver it's called the first house and it's literally the first house because it's built by adam who is the first man right um and it is said to be an earthly replica of a kind of divine prototype that exists in heaven. And this is called the Ever-Inhabited House. And it is said, according to Muslim tradition, that every day you have angels, thousands upon thousands, 70,000 is the favorite number, who are going round and round it, singing songs of praise, prostrating themselves in prayer, praising God. And a vision of this is shown to Muhammad.
最正统的传统，即标准传统，讲述卡巴为什么如此重要的原因。编年史中提到，除了卡巴之外，它还被称为第一所房，它字面意思就是第一所房，因为它是人类始祖阿当建造的，对吧？……据说它是天堂中存在的某种神圣原型的尘世复制品。这被称为“天房”（Ever-Inhabited House）。根据穆斯林的传统，每天都有成千上万的天使——7万人是最喜欢的数字——围着它转圈，唱着赞美歌，俯伏祈祷，赞美真主。而穆罕默德看到了这一切的异象。
He journeys from Mecca to Jerusalem, and he then ascends on a kind of a magical horse, a heavenly horse called the Barak, up into the heavens. And in the seventh heaven, he sees all of this. He sees the angels going around the Kaaba. And this all happens in one night. So it's a spectacular miracle. So the Kaaba is, in a way, a kind of earthly image of this glorious prototype in heaven. And it plays an absolutely key role in the sacred history of the earth and of humanity.
他从麦加旅行到耶路撒冷，然后骑着一种神奇的马——被称为巴拉克（Al-Buraq）的天马升入诸天。在第七重天，他看到了这一切。他看到天使们围绕着卡巴。这一切都发生在短短的一个夜晚。所以这是一个壮观的奇迹。因此，卡巴在某种程度上是天堂中这个光荣原型的尘世影像。它在地球和人类的神圣历史中发挥着绝对关键的作用。
Because it is, according to Muslim tradition, it's where the Garden of Eden stood. In Mecca. In Mecca. It's where Adam was created. So the very spot where Adam was created, it's where he names the animals. And he builds the Kaaba from stones that, again, according to tradition, are taken from the floor of paradise. So the original stones are from paradise.
因为根据穆斯林传统，这里就是伊甸园曾经所在的地方。在麦加。在麦加。这里是阿当被造的地方。所以阿当被造的那个地方，就是他给动物命名的地方。他用同样根据传统从乐园地面上取来的石头建造了卡巴。所以最初的石头是来自乐园的。
And they're radiant. And this is a time of darkness. They illuminate the darkness. And you remember the black stone I mentioned? Yes. And you kind of touch it when you start your circumambulation. Yeah. One of the most popular traditions, one of the most kind of vital traditions is that the black stone is the only surviving remnant of these original heavenly stones.
而且它们散发着光芒。这是一个充满黑暗的时代。它们照亮了黑暗。你还记得我提到的那块黑石吗？是的。当你开始绕行时，你会去触摸它。是的。最流行的传统之一、最核心的传统之一，就是黑石是这些最初的天堂石块中唯一幸存的残余。
So the rest of the Kaaba therefore has been renovated. It's been obliterated by the flood. i see so noah's flood yeah it obliterates it and people forget about it people forget that it was ever there and then abraham turns up and gabriel gibriel reveals to him the site and he rebuilds it with his son Ishmael. And again, in the verse that I quoted, it says there is this clear sign, the standing place of Abraham, which is Makham Ibrahim. And this is a stone that, according to Muslim tradition, is imprinted with his feet, and it's still adjacent to the Kaaba. And this is the black stone? No. tradition is imprinted with his feet and it's still adjacent to the carver and this is the black stone no the black stone is the black stone is embedded into uh the the fabric of the the
因此，卡巴的其余部分后来得到了翻新。它被洪水冲毁了。我明白了。所以诺亚的大洪水？是的，它把它冲毁了，人们忘记了它。人们忘记它曾经存在过，然后易卜拉欣出现了，加百列向他显现了遗址，他和他的儿子伊斯梅尔一起重建了它。同样，在我引用的那节经文中，它说有一个清晰的标志，即易卜拉欣的立足处，也就是马卡姆·易卜拉欣（Makham Ibrahim）。根据穆斯林的传统，这是一块印有他脚印的石头，它仍然紧挨着卡巴。这就是黑石吗？不。
carver the the stone with the footprints of abraham yeah the the maham ibrahim is next to the next to the carver okay sorry so it's part of it's part i got confused yeah John. Well, as well you may, because there are an awful lot of stones in this story. And actually, the confusion in a way is part of the story, as we will see. So Abraham rebuilds the Kaaba, and he then, basically, he's the guy who initiates the hard rituals. So the circumcision. Yeah, the prayers, all this kind of stuff so he's he's going to going to the spot where the carbanhav stands he's he's rebuilding it he's doing the circumambulation this is the prototype for the hajj that muslims to this day
传统上印有他的脚印的石头仍然紧挨着卡巴，这就是黑石吗？不，黑石是嵌入卡巴结构中的……而印有易卜拉欣脚印的石头，是的，马卡姆·易卜拉欣就在卡巴旁边。哦，对不起，所以它是……它是其中的一部分，我搞糊涂了，约翰。嗯，你当然可能会糊涂，因为这个故事里有非常多的石头。事实上，正如我们将看到的，这种混乱本身就是故事的一部分。所以易卜拉欣重建了卡巴，然后，基本上，他是发起那些严厉仪式的人。比如割礼。是的，祈祷，诸如此类的事情。所以他要去卡巴伫立的地方，他要重建它，他要进行绕行，这就是今天穆斯林仍在进行的朝觐的原型——
are doing um and of course abraham is a monotheist he he understands the oneness of God, which is the absolute foundational concept within Islam. And he teaches the Arabs of Mecca this kind of radiant truth. But over the course of the centuries and then the millennia that follow the time of Abraham, the Arabs start to forget this and they start to fill the Kaaba with idols. Yes. Yeah. One in particular in particular hubal which is a particularly popular god but there are lots and lots of different gods um and some of them go so far as to do the circumambulation naked that is not good form tom i think and there's there's one couple a guy called isaf and a woman called nailer who who go into the Kaaba and they have sex in the Kaaba.
嗯，当然，易卜拉欣是一神论者，他理解真主的独一性，这是伊斯兰教绝对基础的概念。他向麦加的阿拉伯人传授了这种发光的真理。但在易卜拉欣时代之后的几个世纪甚至几千年里，阿拉伯人开始忘记这一点，他们开始用偶像填满卡巴。是的。是的。特别是其中一个叫胡巴尔（Hubal）的神，特别受欢迎，但还有许许多多不同的神……有些人甚至赤身裸体地进行绕行，汤姆，我觉得这可不太好。还有一对男女——一个叫伊萨夫（Isaf）的男人和一个叫纳伊拉（Naila）的女人——他们走进卡巴，在卡巴里发生了性关系。
And Dominic, you mentioned about being confused by the number of stones. They are turned into stone. So they become, you know, yet further stones. And the Meccans start worshipping them. Oh, no. And they start offering them sacrifice. So, I mean, it couldn't be more wicked. Yeah.
多米尼克，你提到对石头的数量感到糊涂。他们变成了石头。所以他们变成了……你知道的，变成了更多的石头。麦加人开始崇拜他们。哦，不。他们开始向他们献祭。所以，我的意思是，再没有比这更邪恶的了。是的。
Because you only offer sacrifice to God. You certainly don't worship stones. You certainly don't worship stones that were originally people having sex. I mean, all of this is very, very bad. But it is all very lucrative. And it makes Mecca a place of pilgrimage for all the various pagan tribes who start to come around. This is where Muhammad comes in. He's born in Mecca, right? He's where Muhammad comes in. He's born in Mecca, right?
因为你只向真主献祭。你当然不崇拜石头。你当然不崇拜原本是进行性行为的人的石头。我的意思是，这一切都非常非常糟糕。但这一切都非常赚钱。这使得麦加成为所有蜂拥而至的各种异教部落的朝圣之地。这就是穆罕默德登场的地方。他出生在麦加，对吧？这就是穆罕默德登场的地方。他出生在麦加，对吧？
He's born in Mecca. He's born in Mecca. As you said, he has his revelation at 40. And basically, it's God, as Gabriel had come to Abraham, so now he comes to Muhammad and he says, you've got to sort this out. You've got to clean up this town. And so Muhammad demands the destruction of the idols.
他出生在麦加。他出生在麦加。正如你所说，他在40岁时得到了启示。基本上，真主就像加百列曾来到易卜拉欣那里一样，现在他来到了穆罕默德面前，他说：你必须解决这个问题。你必须清理这座城镇。于是穆罕默德要求销毁偶像。
He demands the end of idolatry. He preaches the truth, the demand for submission, Islam, to the one God. And this doesn't go down well with the guardians of the shrine because they can see that it's going to damage their income. And so basically they end up driving Muhammad out and his followers. And this is the Hijidra, the Exodus. He goes to Medina, to Yathrib, which becomes Medina, the city of the prophet in 622. But Muhammad is down, but he's not out. And he and his followers, they make themselves the bosses of Yathrib.
他要求结束偶像崇拜。他宣讲真理，要求向唯一的真主顺从（Islam）。这并没有受到神庙守护者的欢迎，因为他们能看出这会损害他们的收入。因此，他们最终把穆罕默德和他的追随者赶了出去。这就是希吉拉（Hijra），即出走。他在622年去了麦地那，去到了叶斯里卜（Yathrib），后来那里变成了麦地那，即先知的城市。但穆罕默德虽然受挫，却没有被打倒。他和他的追随者使自己成为了叶斯里卜的主人。
It becomes the city of the prophet Medina and at 6 30 he's able to come back in triumph into Mecca and he overthrows all the idols except for one which is an image of of the virgin and the baby Jesus that's that's allowed to stay and he burns the lot and he topples the stones within the Kaaba that they've been worshipping. And as he does so, a woman emerges from one of the stones. And she is a black woman with gray hair and she tears at her face with her nails. She's naked. She pulls at her hair and she cries out in woe. And this is Naila, who has been brought back to life to witness the destruction of the stone that she had been imprisoned in.
这里成了先知的城市麦地那，在630年，他得以凯旋重返麦加，他推翻了所有的偶像，除了一个——那是圣母和圣婴耶稣的画像，那个被允许留下来——他烧毁了其余的一切，并推翻了卡巴内他们一直崇拜的石头。正当他这样做时，一个女人从一块石头里钻了出来。那是一个黑皮肤的女人，有着灰白的头发，她用指甲抓挠自己的面庞。她赤身裸体。她扯着自己的头发，悲痛地大喊。这就是纳伊拉，她复活了，来见证她曾被囚禁其中的那块石头的毁灭。
And the devil is watching this and he summons all his progeny around him and he cries out in woe, abandon all hope that the community of Mohammed will ever revert to idolatry after this day of theirs and uh and so it happens because the kaba is re-consecrated to um to the worship of the one god and it becomes the great center of monotheistic pilgrimage and the tradition of the hajj that had been established by abraham is re-established but right i wondered if there was going to be a but okay but there is there is a further cycle of destruction and renovation to come because uh muhammad dies his followers uh conquer a great empire and a particular family rises to the rule of this empire and this is the emmaids the dynasty the uh. The first of the Umayyad caliphs, the rulers of the Islamic world, is a man called Muawiyah.
恶魔正在看着这一切，他把所有的后代召集在自己周围，悲痛地大喊：抛弃一切幻想吧，在他们这一天之后，穆罕默德的社群绝不会再回到偶像崇拜中去了。事情果真如此，因为卡巴被重新奉献给对独一真主的崇拜，它成为了单一神论朝圣的伟大中心，而由易卜拉欣建立的朝觐传统也得以重建——但是……我一直在想是不是会有个“但是”？好吧，但是，未来还会有另一轮的毁灭与翻新，因为穆罕默德去世了，他的追随者征服了一个伟大的帝国，一个特定的家族崛起并统治了这个帝国，这就是倭马亚王朝（Umayyad），即伍麦叶王朝……倭马亚哈里发中的第一位、伊斯兰世界的统治者是一个名叫穆阿维亚（Muawiyah）的人。
And he's said to have gone on hard twice. And he's the man who first provides the Kaaba with the kiswap, which is the great black silk covering. He dies and he leaves behind a son called Yazid. And Yazid is a notorious playboy. So he's debauched, he's drunk. And the most sinister thing of all, he keeps a monkey as a pet. Very, very bad form. Yeah, it's bad form. devoted and austere followers of the teachings of Muhammad. And there's one in particular guy called Abdullah ibn al-Zubayr, who is very old. And he was a boy in Muhammad's lifetime, remembers him. So he's a kind of living link to the age of the prophet. And while Yazd is off conquering the fertile crescent and establishing his rule over the great cities of Mesopotamia
据说他曾进行过两次朝觐。他是第一个为卡巴提供基斯瓦（Kiswap）的人，也就是那块巨大的黑色丝绸帷幕。他去世后，留下了一个名叫耶齐德（Yazid）的儿子。而耶齐德是个臭名昭著的花花公子。他生活放荡，酗酒。最阴险的是，他养了一只宠物猴。非常非常不好的风气。是的，这风气很坏。虔诚且简朴的穆罕默德教导追随者……其中有一个特别的人叫阿卜杜拉·伊本·祖拜尔（Abdullah ibn al-Zubayr），他年纪非常大。他在穆罕默德在世时还是个孩子，还记得他。所以他是连接先知时代的某种活生生的纽带。当耶齐德正在征服肥沃月湾并确立他对美索不达米亚各大城市的统治时——
and Syria and so on, ibn al-Zubayr is retreating into the desert to the sacred house. Yazd's army lays siege to Ibn al-Zubayr. He bombards the Kaaba with catapults. He destroys it at the very moment when it looks as though the whole complex is going to fall, that Ibn al-Zubayr's resistance is doomed. News arrives that Yazd has died. And his army, with that news, gives up its siege and drifts back to Syria. With his death, you have massive Umayyad infighting.
和叙利亚等等，伊本·祖拜尔退回到沙漠中的圣房。耶齐德的军队对伊本·祖拜尔发动了围攻。他用投石机轰炸卡巴。就在整个建筑群看似要陷落、伊本·祖拜尔的抵抗注定失败的那一刻，消息传来，耶齐德死了。随着这个消息，他的军队放弃了围攻，退回了叙利亚。随着他的死亡，倭马亚王朝内部爆发了大规模的内讧。
And so Ibn al-Zubayr is able to kind of reestablish his authority and his control in the desert. Now, the problem that Ibn al-Zubayr faces is what to do about the Kaaba, because Yaz's men and their catapults have destroyed it. So there's a lot of debate among his followers. that they should leave it as it is. And this is argued particularly by a man called Abdullah ibn Abbas, who argues that it should not be rebuilt because he feared that destroying it would set a precedent to tear it down and rebuild it. So in other words, if you rebuild it, that suggests that you can just keep doing it and doing it and doing it. Ibn al-Zubayr himself responds to this, by God, is there no one among you who would not mend the house of his parents? So how would you wish me to do otherwise with the house of god when i watch it falling apart piece by piece and he consults and basically most people agree with him that it should be demolished completely
因此，伊本·祖拜尔得以在沙漠中重新确立他的权威和控制。现在，伊本·祖拜尔面临的问题是如何处理卡巴，因为耶齐德的人和他们的投石机已经把它摧毁了。所以他的追随者中有很多辩论，他们认为应该保持原样。这一点尤其由一个名叫阿卜杜拉·伊本·阿巴斯（Abdullah ibn Abbas）的人提出，他认为不应该重建，因为他担心摧毁它会开创一个先例，让人可以不断地拆除并重建它。换句话说，如果你重建它，那就暗示你可以一直这样做、这样做、这样做。伊本·祖拜尔本人对此回应道：以真主之名，难道你们当中就没有人会去修缮他父母的房子吗？当我看着真主的房子一块块地倒塌时，你们怎么能希望我采取别的做法呢？他进行了协商，基本上大多数人都同意应该彻底拆除它——
that the the ruins should be swept aside and it should be rebuilt from scratch not as it had been so not as it yeah you know the original but but it should be rebuilt as Muhammad had described seeing it in his vision of the original Kaaba, so the one in heaven. So it should be built to correspond to that as closely as possible. And all kinds of stories are told about this process. So we're in the 680s or so now, Tom, is that right? Exactly. Yeah. Exactly.
废墟应该被清扫干净，应该从头开始重建，而不是像原来的那样——你知道的，不是原本的样子——而是应该按照穆罕默德在关于最初卡巴的异象中所描述的那样重建，也就是天上那座卡巴的样子。所以它的建造应该尽可能地与之对应。关于这个过程流传着各种各样的故事。汤姆，我们现在大概是在680年代左右，对吗？完全正确。是的。完全正确。
But we're also very much in a dimension of the supernatural yeah so various stories are told about the process of the rebuilding of the carver so it's said that um the original foundations had been laid down by abraham are miraculously rediscovered a mysterious text is found during the renovation work assuring um everyone who visits the sanctuary that they will receive divine favor and most sensationally of all the black stone is found it's dug up oh so the black stone until this point had been lost or according to according to this version right it's dug up the whole sanctuary begins to to um to tremble and on the stone it said is stamped the name and title of god i am ala the
但我们也很大程度上处于超自然的维度。是的。所以关于卡巴重建的过程流传着各种故事：据说易卜拉欣奠定的最初地基被奇迹般地重新发现了；在翻新工作中发现了一段神秘的文字，向访问圣殿的所有人保证他们将获得神的恩宠；而最轰动的是，黑石被找到了，它被挖出来了。哦，所以黑石到这个时候一直都是丢失的，或者根据这个版本——它被挖出来了，整个圣殿开始颤抖，据说石头上印着真主的名字和称号：我是安拉，巴卡的主。
lord of bakka so palpable signs that this project of renovation is blessed by god and is indeed taking the muslim people back to the primordial beginnings of the prophetic tradition so uh ibn aziz has clearly made the right decision. Meanwhile, however, the Umayyads have basically patched things up. And one of them has established his rule over the Fertile Crescent and the provinces beyond. And this is a man who very much featured in our episode on Muhammad, Abdul Malik. He's centered in syria um he he very much regards jerusalem as a holy city um he builds the dome of the rock so the great building on on the the ancient temple mount uh people you know if you think of jerusalem they the the great building
这些都是显而易见的迹象，表明这项翻新工程得到了真主的祝福，并且确实将穆斯林带回了先知传统的远古之初。所以伊本·祖拜尔显然做出了正确的决定。然而与此同时，倭马亚人基本上已经收拾好了残局。其中一人在肥沃月湾及以外的省份确立了统治，这就是在我们关于穆罕默德的那集节目中着重介绍过的人物——阿卜杜勒·马利克（Abdul Malik）。他以叙利亚为中心，他非常尊崇耶路撒冷为圣城，他建造了圆顶清真寺（Dome of the Rock）——也就是建在古代圣殿山上的宏伟建筑。如果你想到耶路撒冷，人们会想到那座拥有金色圆顶的宏伟建筑——
with the golden dome that's the dome of the rock um and it becomes an object of pilgrimage while people are unable to visit the Kaaba, the sacred house in the desert. But clearly, if Abdul Malik is going to claim the rule of the entire caliphate, the entire Muslim world, he cannot allow Ibn al-Zubayr to maintain his control over the Kaaba. So in 691, he sends an army against Ibn al-Zubayr. There's a six-month siege. The catapults are wheeled out. And once again, the entire structure is reduced to rubble. And the defenders are killed, Ibn al-Zubayr among them. And Abdul Malik takes control of the shattered sanctuary. And even though Abdul Malik is now, he has no rival as caliph, as the deputy of God, there are lots of Muslims who damn him as the man
那就是圆顶清真寺。当人们无法访问沙漠中的圣房卡巴时，它就成了朝圣的对象。但显然，如果阿卜杜勒·马利克想要宣称对整个哈里发国、整个穆斯林世界的统治，他就不能允许伊本·祖拜尔维持对卡巴的控制。因此，在691年，他派出一支军队讨伐伊本·祖拜尔。经过了六个月的围城，投石机被推了出来，整个建筑再次沦为废墟。防御者被杀，伊本·祖拜尔也在其中。阿卜杜勒·马利克控制了这座破碎的圣殿。尽管阿卜杜勒·马利克现在作为哈里发、作为真主的代表已经没有了竞争对手，但仍有许多穆斯林谴责他是那个摧毁了真主圣房的人。
who destroyed the sacred house of God. And there are, Ameer propagandists have to kind of deal with this. And so they say that actually the van the true vandal had been ibn el-zabaya and because he knocked it down because he knocked it down and the abdul malik in rebuilding it he is the one who's now restoring it to its pristine condition so that's what he does right and in 693 he goes on pilgrimage to the kaba uh he he rebuilds it yet again and basically this is the structure that that exists now um now. It's built either by Ibn Al-Zubayr or by Abdul Malik. There is debate about it. These stories are so complicated that
倭马亚的宣传人员不得不处理这个问题。于是他们说，其实真正的破坏者是伊本·祖拜尔，因为是他把它推倒的；而阿卜杜勒·马利克在重建它时，他才是现在将它恢复到原始状态的人。所以他就是这么做的，对吧？然后在693年，他去卡巴朝圣，他又一次重建了它。基本上，这就是现在依然存在的结构……现在。它是建于伊本·祖拜尔之手，还是建于阿卜杜勒·马利克之手？对此尚有争论。这些故事太复杂了，以至于——
it's hard to be sure. But basically, that seems to be the kind of upshot. And Abdul Malik has control over the Dome of the Rock. So that's the house of, the revered house on the Mount of Jerusalem, as it's called. And he has the house of God. And so to us, a poet at his court says, talking about Abdul Malik, belong the two houses. And Abdul Malik is a tremendously impressive state builder, isn't he? I mean, he is the Umayyad caliph. Yes. Because he introduces the currency in an army and, you know, he sort of welds the whole thing into an empire. He also seems to be the one who really starts to hammer home the significance of Muhammad as the prophet of God.
很难确定。但基本上，这似乎就是结果。阿卜杜勒·马利克控制了圆顶清真寺。所以那是耶路撒冷山上被称为尊贵之家的建筑，正如人们所说的那样。他拥有真主的殿。因此，他宫廷里的一位诗人谈到阿卜杜勒·马利克时说，两座殿宇都属于他。阿卜杜勒·马利克是一位极其令人印象深刻的国家建设者，不是吗？我的意思是，他是倭马亚王朝的哈里发。是的。因为他引入了货币和军队，而且你知道的，他把这一切融合成了一个帝国。他似乎也是那个真正开始强调穆罕默德作为真主先知之重要性的人。
So he puts Muhammad's name on his coins. He puts Muhammad's name on his coins. He puts Muhammad's name on the dome of the rock. And these are the first mentions of Muhammad that you get from a central imperial figure within the emergent caliphate. And in time, the role that Abdul Malik had described to Jerusalem as one of the great sacred centers comes to be downplayed. Jerusalem comes to slightly be put in the shadows. And it's put in the shadows by the rituals of the Hajj, by the sacred geography of Mecca. And absolutely by the 8th century, by the 9th century, the centrality of the Hajj and of Mecca and of the Kaaba is indisputable. Everybody knows where it
因此，他把穆罕默德的名字印在了硬币上。他把穆罕默德的名字印在硬币上。他把穆罕默德的名字印在圆顶清真寺上。这些是你在新兴哈里发国中央帝国人物那里听到的对穆罕默德的首次提及。随着时间的推移，阿卜杜勒·马利克将耶路撒冷描述为伟大圣地之一的角色开始被淡化。耶路撒冷逐渐退居幕后。它因朝觐的仪式和麦加的神圣地理位置而被淡化。到了公元8世纪和9世纪，朝觐、麦加以及克尔白的核心地位绝对是无可争议的。每个人都知道它
is. Everybody knows that it's a great central pilgrimage. It's still subject to occasional desecrations. So in 930, you have an army of militant Shiites. So Shiites are one of the, would be regarded by mainstream Muslim Sunnis as a kind of heretical sect. Any Shiite listeners, apologies for that description, but I'm adopting the perspective of the Sunni guardians of the Kaaba. So militant Shiites, they attack Mecca. And a bit like the Elamites making off with the statue of Marduk, they make off with the black stone, which is very bad form. And by this point, the Amayads have been toppled and replaced by the Abbasids,
在哪里。每个人都知道这是一个伟大的朝圣中心。它仍然不时遭受亵渎。所以在公元930年，你有一支激进的什叶派军队。因此什叶派是主流穆斯林逊尼派视为某种异端派别的一群人。如果有任何什叶派听众，为这种描述道歉，但我采用的是克尔白逊尼派守护者的视角。所以激进的什叶派袭击了麦加。有点像埃兰人带走了马尔杜克雕像一样，他们带走了黑石，这非常不合规矩。此时，倭马亚王朝已被推翻并被阿拔斯王朝取代，
who as the kind of the ruling dynasty, and the Abbasids have to ransom it back, which they do about kind of a couple of decades past. And they cough up and get the black stone back. And then in 1626, there were floods in Mecca and the walls of the Kaaba collapse and they're rebuilt with granite stone. And so that basically is a structure that is still standing there to this day. So the question is, if you're not a Muslim, what on earth are you to make of that story?
作为统治王朝，阿拔斯王朝不得不花钱把它赎回来，他们在二十年前后就这样做了。他们付了钱并取回了黑石。然后到了1626年，麦加发生洪水，克尔白的墙壁倒塌，人们用花岗岩石对其进行了重建。所以基本上，这就是至今仍屹立在那里的建筑。所以问题是，如果你不是穆斯林，你究竟该如何看待这个故事？
So maybe we should take a break and you can kind of gird your loins and then you can tell us what a non-Muslim would make of all this story after the break. So if you're a Muslim, I suppose you can stop listening now. Absolutely. You don't care. But if you're not, come back after the break and Tom will solve the mysteries. I won't solve the mystery, Dominic, because I think it's absolutely essential to say that I think the solution to this mystery is beyond the ability of secular historians to answer. Well, what a selling point. Come back after the break and Tom won't solve the mystery.
所以也许我们应该休息一下，你可以振作一下精神，然后给我们讲讲非穆斯林在休息后会如何看待这个故事。所以如果你是穆斯林，我想你现在可以停止收听了。当然。你不在乎。但如果你不是，休息后来听汤姆解开谜团。我不会解开这个谜团的，多米尼克，因为我认为绝对有必要说明，我认为这个谜团的解决超出了世俗历史学家的能力范围。嗯，多好的卖点啊。休息后来听汤姆解开谜团。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are talking about the Kaaba, the sacred site at the centre of Mecca. Tom Holland, in the first half, you explained the you're sort of balancing the desire to be,
我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐就是一切》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们揭开娱乐的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权益，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史就是一切》（The Rest Is History）。我们正在讨论克尔白，也就是麦加中心的圣地。汤姆·霍兰德，在上半场中，你解释了你在保持尊重的同时，也带着我们对待其他任何历史时期时所持有的怀疑心态。
as it were, respectful with the sort of the sceptical mindset that we bring to any other period of history. But I think it's also the problem is that essentially the Muslim account is the only account we have. So that's the problem. The explanation of why the Kaaba is sacred is rooted in a history that reaches back to the beginnings of the world and figures who will be entirely familiar to Christian or Jewish listeners, but who are not generally accepted by historians as having been historical. As in Adam. As in Adam, but also in Abraham. Abraham is, I think, not generally viewed as a historical figure. Yeah, because we have no archaeological evidence
但我也认为问题在于，基本上穆斯林的说辞是我们拥有的唯一说辞。这就是问题所在。解释克尔白为什么是圣地的根源在于一段追溯到世界之初的历史，这些历史人物对基督徒或犹太听众来说将完全熟悉，但历史学家通常不承认他们具有历史真实性。比如亚当。就像亚当一样，还有亚伯拉罕。我认为，亚伯拉罕通常不被视为一个历史人物。是的，因为我们没有考古证据
that somebody called Abraham was strolling around, you know, the Levant or whatever. So that's an issue, but there's also a kind of additional problem. I mean, if Mecca is this great centre of pilgrimage and the Kaaba is, you know, is this incredibly sacred spot, even if it's become a pagan centre of ritual,
证明一个叫亚伯拉罕的人曾在黎凡特或其他什么地方闲逛。所以这是一个问题，但也有一个额外的问题。我的意思是，如果麦加是这个伟大的朝圣中心，而克尔白是这个极其神圣的地方，即使它已经成为一个异教仪式的中心，
there doesn't seem to be any mention of it whatsoever outside the Muslim tradition. But where would such a mention, Eastern Roman, Persian accounts or something, that this is the thing that the Arabs do? Ever since the 17th century, there have been scholars who've argued that there are references to it in classical geographers. So there's a historian, Diodorus Siculus, writing in the first century, who
在穆斯林传统之外似乎没有任何关于它的提及。但是这样的提及会在哪里呢，比如东罗马、波斯帝国的记载或其他什么，证明这是阿拉伯人做的事？自17世纪以来，一直有学者争辩说古典地理学家对它有所提及。所以有一位生活在公元一世纪的历史学家西西里的狄奥多罗斯，他
writes about a temple much revered by the Arabs. And in the 17th century, this was argued by Christian scholars that this might be a reference to Mecca. But the problem is that Diodorus Siculus, when he's writing about this, he is clearly writing about Northwest Arabia, and Mecca is in the region called the Hejaz, which is kind of more central. So that doesn't seem to work. Ptolemy, the great geographer, he writes to a place called Macaraba. And there are still scholars who think that that might be a reference to Mecca, but the etymology doesn't really work. And I think, again, pretty much the consensus of secular academics is that this, again, is not a reference to Mecca. And in fact, the earliest unambiguous reference to Mecca
在第一世纪写作的历史学家狄奥多罗斯·西库罗斯（Diodorus Siculus），他撰写了一座备受阿拉伯人尊崇的神庙。在17世纪，基督教学者认为这可能是指麦加。但问题是，当狄奥多罗斯·西库罗斯撰写关于这部分的内容时，他显然是在写阿拉伯西北部，而麦加位于被称为“汉志”（Hejaz）的地区，这个地区相对更偏中心一些。所以这似乎行不通。托勒密，伟大的地理学家，他写到一个名为“马卡拉巴”（Macaraba）的地方。仍然有一些学者认为这可能是指麦加，但词源上真的说不通。并且我认为，世俗学术界大致的共识同样是，这也不是指麦加。事实上，在古代文献中、在《古兰经》之外最早明确提及麦加的记录是在741年，出现在一份名为《拜占庭-阿拉伯编年史》的文件中。而且它当时被定位在美索不达米亚，而不是汉志。所以你在那里有一种感觉，即这座城市有点像漂浮着，这有点像卡米洛特。我想我们在关于穆罕默德的那期节目中讨论过这一点。
in ancient literature outside the Quran is 741 in something called the Byzantine Arab Chronicle. And then it's located in Mesopotamia and not in the Hejaz. So what you have the sense there is of a city that is kind of floating around, that it's a bit like Camelot. I think we talked about this in the episode on Muhammad. On Muhammad, yeah. So all of that is kind of tricky. And again, if you look at the Quran, which is in dispute of, you know,
关于穆罕默德，是的。所以所有这些都有点棘手。同样，如果你看看《古兰经》——毫无疑问，这是主要的来源。伊斯兰教中关于克尔白的传统最终正是来源于此——巴卡（Baka）等于麦加（Mecca）吗？再次说明，我认为这完全不是不证自明的。因此，稍微扰乱这种说法的一点是，《古兰经》中的《诗篇》实际上提到了巴卡。所以在《诗篇》第84篇中，你会看到：“靠你有力量、心中想往锡安大道的人，这人便为福！他们经过流泪谷（巴卡谷），叫这谷变为泉源之地……”但这可能只是巧合，汤姆？我的意思是，这完全可能是一个巧合，但同样它也可能……
this is the prime source. This is where ultimately the traditions about the Kaaba come from in Islam. Does Baka equal Mecca, i.e. Mecca? Again, I don't think it's entirely self-evident that it is. So one thing that slightly queers the pitch is that Baka is actually mentioned in the psalms so there's there's in psalm 84 you get blessed is the man whose strength is in the in whose heart are the ways of them those who passing through the valley of the baka they make it a spring but that could could be a coincidence though tom i mean it could it could absolutely be a coincidence but equally it might
这是主要的来源。这正是伊斯兰教中关于克尔白传统的最终来源。巴卡（Baka）等于麦加吗，也就是麦加？同样，我认为它是否完全等同并非不言自喻。有一个稍微有点干扰性的因素是，圣咏中其实提到了巴卡，所以在诗篇第84篇中，你会看到“靠你有力量、心中想往锡安大道的，这人便为有福。他们经过流泪谷（巴卡谷），叫这谷变为泉源之地”。但这可能只是个巧合，汤姆。我的意思是，这完全可能只是个巧合，但同样它也可能
not be okay uh and presumably if it's not then that is you know the psalmist is not going to be referring to somewhere in the middle of arabia so that's a that's a complication and then you have the the the kind of peculiar fact that the kaba is a cube and it's peculiar because cubes seem to have had a peculiarly and again i, I'm going to use the word, sacral hold on the Arabs for centuries before the coming of Muhammad. And it covers a huge geographical spread. So you have Christian writers who, you know, they're looking at Petra, regions like that in the northwest of Arabia. And they describe the Arabs worshipping cubes as incarnations of their gods.
这可不太妙，嗯，而且可以推测，如果不是这样的话，你知道，诗篇作者就不会指阿拉伯的某个中部地区了，所以这本身就是一个复杂的问题。然后你还会遇到一个奇怪的事实，那就是克尔白（Kaaba）是一个立方体。这很奇怪，因为在穆罕默德到来之前的几个世纪里，立方体似乎对阿拉伯人有着某种特殊的——再次声明，我要用这个词——神圣的吸引力。而且它的地理跨度非常大。所以你会看到一些基督教作家，你知道的，他们在审视佩特拉（Petra）以及阿拉伯西北部这样的地区。他们将阿拉伯人对立方体的崇拜描述为他们神明的化身。
Again, Christian writers, not necessarily very reliable. You know, they're projecting things onto the people that they're writing about. But it is a kind of intriguing coincidence and anyone who's been to petra will i'm sure have seen these kind of strange cuboid structures um raised up on rocks as you go down towards the uh the site of the city and in the south as well i mean there's an absolutely intriguing uh carver another carver which um appears in a place called nadran which in the early 6th century was the site of a massacre of christians by jewish king i mean again it's all kind of very weird there's a jewish king in the south of south of arabia and he massacres these christians and and they raise a huge um they raise a shrine in honor of these martyrs and they call it the carver so
再说一次，基督教作家的话不一定很可靠。你知道，他们把一些东西投射到了他们所写的人身上。但这是一种耐人寻味巧合，任何去过佩特拉的人我确信都见过这种奇怪的长方体结构，当你走向那座城市的遗址以及南部时，它们在岩石上拔地而起。我的意思是，在南部，绝对有一个非常耐人寻味的大卡尔巴（carver），另一个卡尔巴，它出现在一个叫纳季兰（Najran）的地方。在六世纪初，这里曾是一个犹太国王屠杀基督徒的遗址。我的意思是，这同样非常诡异，阿拉伯南部竟然有一个犹太国王，他屠杀了这些基督徒，然后他们竖起了一个巨大的——他们为了纪念这些殉道者建立了一座圣殿，并称之为卡尔巴，所以
what i think you're getting with this is a sense that cubes have some kind of significance for the Arabs in a way that we don't entirely understand. And then there's a third question, which is the Makam Ibrahim. So the place where the standing place of Abraham. And is that to be identified with the stone that stands next to the Kaaba in Mecca? And again, there's a kind of problem with that because in late antiquity, the period when the Quran seems to have been written, all the traditions about Abraham are associating him with the desert regions beyond the Holy Land. There are absolutely no traditions that link him to the Hejaz, to Mecca. It's all slightly tricky. But the idea that Bakr is Mecca, that Mecca stands in the Hejaz, that Abraham went there, these are all propositions that come to be completely taken for granted by the biographers of Muhammad, by commentators on the Quran, and so on. And essentially, that is the state of play. If you're a Muslim, you believe that. If you're not a Muslim, then I think you say, well, I don't know, case not proven. But Tom, in the 1970s, and then afterwards, there was a school, wasn't there, of kind of non-Muslim revisionist history, which sort of argued, I'm going to massively sort of simplify this, that they argued that a lot of what we think about Islam
我认为你从中体会到的是一种感觉，即立方体对阿拉伯人具有某种我们无法完全理解的重要意义。然后是第三个问题，也就是易卜拉欣站位（Makam Ibrahim）。也就是说，亚伯拉罕站立的地方。这是否可以等同于麦加克尔白旁边的那块石头？这里同样存在一个问题，因为在古代晚期，也就是《古兰经》似乎被编写的时期，所有关于亚伯拉罕的传统都将他与圣地以外的沙漠地区联系在一起。没有任何传统将他与汉志（Hejaz）、与麦加联系起来。这一切都有点棘手。但是，巴克（Bakr）就是麦加，麦加坐落在汉志，亚伯拉罕去过那里，这些观点都被穆罕默德的传记作者、《古兰经》的注释者等等视为理所当然。从根本上说，这就是目前的现状。如果你是穆罕默德的信徒，你就会相信这一点。如果你不是穆罕默德的信徒，那么我想你会说，好吧，我不知道，证据不足。但是，汤姆，在20世纪70年代及以后，曾出现过一个流派，不是吗？一种非穆罕默德历史修正主义学派，他们大致认为——我在这里进行了极大程度的简化——他们认为我们对伊斯兰教的许多看法
was actually constructed much later, further west, after a lot of the conquest has happened, and then sort of retrofitted to create this new ideology that would bolster this new Arab empire. So if that's the case, then is it possible? I mean, I'm saying this with absolutely no knowledge at all, bar a week's study 30 years ago when I was an undergraduate. Is it possible that the Kaaba was constructed much later?
实际上是在很长一段时间之后、更靠西的地方构建的，是在许多征战发生之后，然后以某种方式对其进行改造，以创造出这种能够巩固这个新兴阿拉伯帝国的新意识形态。所以如果是这样的话，有没有可能？我的意思是，我说这话完全没有任何知识储备，除了30年前我读本科时花了一周时间进行的研究。克尔白有没有可能是在更晚的时候建造的？
Let's say at the late 7th century when people were fighting over mecca um it could it all come from there could it have been basically as it were you know i don't want to use the word artificially but you know what i mean could it have all been invented as it were then people who listen to our episode on um roman holidays may remember that we talked about christian pilgrims in the fourth century going to the Holy Land. And basically people would say, oh, this is the house of Peter, or this is where such and such a miracle happened. And the sacred geography is basically invented. But I think the really key figure is Constantine and his mother Helena identifying the true cross of Christ, which enables them to work
比方说，在公元7世纪末，当时人们正在为麦加争夺不休。嗯，这一切会不会都源于那个时期？它基本上是不是可以——你知道的，我不想用“人为”这个词，但你明白我的意思——这一切会不会都是在那个时候被凭空捏造出来的？听过我们关于罗马假日节目的听众可能还记得，我们曾谈到过4世纪前往圣地的基督教朝圣者。基本上人们会说，哦，这是彼得的房子，或者这是某某神迹发生的地方。神圣的地理位置基本上是凭空捏造出来的。但我认为真正关键的人物是君士坦丁（Constantine）和他的母亲海伦娜（Helena），他们认出了真正的基督十字架，这使得他们能够找出
out where the tomb of Jesus was, the site of Golgotha, the place where Christ is crucified, and to build the Church of the Holy Sepulchre. And because there had been presumably various shrines associated with that, but because Constantine brings the heft of a Christian empire to it, he can absolutely identify it. And you see this also with Zoroastrian shrines in the Persian empire, that emperors found Zoroastrian shrines from scratch, which they then claim are eternally ancient. So I think it's possible to imagine that the same thing is happening in arabia that out in the deserts presumably there are a lot of shrines that have a kind of holiness i would
耶稣的墓地在哪里，各各他（Golgotha）的遗址在哪里，基督被钉十字架的地方在哪里，并建造了圣墓教堂（Church of the Holy Sepulchre）。由于以前可能存在各种与之相关的神殿，但由于君士坦丁以一个基督教帝国的威严介入其中，他完全能够确定其位置。你在波斯帝国的祆教（拜火教）神殿中也能看到这一点，皇帝们从无到有地建立祆教神殿，然后声称它们是万古长存的。所以我认为可以想象，同样的事情也正在阿拉伯发生，在沙漠外面，可能有很多神殿都带有一种神圣性，我会
guess any you know any oasis anywhere like that would have had a shrine a place of pilgrimage whatever yeah yeah so so gerald horting who uh is a brilliant scholar of this, he wrote, it seems likely that the Meccan sanctuary was chosen only after the elimination of other possibilities, that in the early Islamic period, a number of possible sanctuary sites gained adherence until finally Mecca became established as the Muslim sanctuary. And presumably what enables it to be established as the Muslim sanctuary is the fact that Abdul Malik has established his rule over the whole of the caliphate and has sufficient heft that he can say, this is where it is. And, you know, which in turn you say, well, why would he fix on Mecca? Presumably, Mecca absolutely has this kind of holy power. It must have been
猜想，你知道的，任何地方的任何绿洲都会有一座神殿，一个朝圣地之类的，对吧，对吧。所以，杰拉尔德·霍丁（Gerald Hawting）——他是这方面的一位杰出学者——他写道：看起来很可能麦加圣地是在排除了其他可能性之后才被选中的，在伊斯兰教早期，许多可能的圣地都获得了追随者，直到最后麦加确立为穆罕默德的圣地。而据推测，使它能够确立为穆罕默德圣地的原因在于，阿卜杜勒·马利克（Abdul Malik）已经将他的统治权确立到了整个哈里发国，并且拥有足够的威望，可以说，这就是它所在的地方。而且，反过来你会说，他为什么会选定麦加呢？据推测，麦加绝对拥有这种神圣的力量。它一定
one of the kind of ancient sanctuaries or one of the shrines that does have this kind of resonance, so that there are absolutely people who are ready to accept that it is indeed what Muslim tradition will come to say it is. I think also, it's telling that Abdul Malik's father had served as the governor of the region. And the general that Abdul Malik sends to defeat Ibn al-Zubayr, 90s? Yeah. Right. Yeah. Which is several decades later than the traditional Islamic historiography would attest. As I said before the second half, I don't think we'll ever know because there's no definitive proof. But I think that there are trace elements of this process, if that is what happened, that you can identify. And that is that there is this kind of enduring sense of resentment that people feel towards Abdul Malik.
是那种古老的圣殿之一，或者说拥有这种共鸣的神殿之一，因此绝对有人准备接受它确实就是穆罕默德传统最终所说的那样。我认为，阿卜杜勒·马利克的父亲曾担任过该地区的总督，这也说明了一些问题。阿卜杜勒·马利克派去击败伊本·祖拜尔（Ibn al-Zubayr）的将军是……90年代？对吧。没错。是的。这比传统的伊斯兰史学所证明的时间要晚几十年。正如我在前半部分之前所说的那样，我认为我们永远不会知道，因为没有确凿的证据。但我认为，这个过程的痕迹——如果这确实发生过的话——是可以识别出来的。那就是人们对阿卜杜勒·马利克有一种持久的怨恨情绪。
He is damned as a man who sense that the house of God might not always have stood rooted to the spot in Mecca. So there's this scholar who writes at the time of the prophet, may God save him and give him peace. Our faces were all turned in one direction, but after the death of the prophet, we turned ourselves hither and thither. So, you know, who knows what that precisely is a memory of but i think also you get it in the sense of the strangeness that you picked up on do you know there are a lot of stones and that they all they're endlessly kind of shifting this way and that so the carver is it is endlessly being demolished and being rebuilt it's being you know demolished through all the stuff with the prophets, with Adam and Abraham
他被诅咒为一个认为真主的房子可能并不总是扎根于麦加的人。所以有一位学者在先知时代（愿真主拯救他并赐予他和平）写道：我们的面孔都转向同一个方向，但在先知死后，我们转向了四面八方。所以，你知道的，谁知道这究竟是对什么的记忆呢？但我认为你也能从你所注意到的那种诡异感中体会到这一点。你知道，有很多石头，它们一直在这样或那样地变动着，所以卡尔巴（carver）不断地被拆毁和重建，它被（你知道的）通过先知亚当和易卜拉欣所经历的一切被拆毁
and so on, but also within historical time with all the various wars between Yazid and Ibn Azubayr and Abdul Malik. The mosque that encloses it, according to tradition, gets kind of destroyed and rebuilt. There's a sacred well there that gets lost twice and refound. The Mahkam Ibrahim, the stone with supposedly the imprint of Abraham's feet, that's always moving around all the time. It gets caught up in a flood. It gets transported by human hand. And then you have the black stone. And there are so many different contradictory stories told about that. So the prime story, I think, is the one that I mentioned at the beginning,
等等，而且在历史时期内，随着耶齐德（Yazid）和伊本·祖拜尔以及阿卜杜勒·马利克之间的各种战争而不断变化。根据传统，环绕它的清真寺遭到某种程度的破坏和重建。那里有一口神圣的井，丢失了两次又被重新发现。易卜拉欣站位，那块据称带有亚伯拉罕脚印的石头，一直在不停地移动。它卷入了一场洪水。它被人类的手搬运过。然后你有了黑石。关于这块石头，有太多不同且相互矛盾的故事。因此，主要的传说，我认为就是我在开头提到的那个，
that it's one of the original stones that Adam used to build the shrine. But there is also a story that Adam had found it and transported it with Ishmael all the way, which again implies that perhaps the original shrine was somewhere else. There's others who claim that Ibn al-Zubayr had placed it in an ark of the kind that Moses used to transport the Torah around the desert. So the sheer multiplicity of stories suggest perhaps a certain sense that there's a strangeness to the process. But I think also, obviously, what they also suggest is a sense of awe before the potency of the Kaaba as an emblem of faith in the one God. So that if you're not a Muslim, if you're a skeptical cast of mind, you could say, well, this suggests that perhaps the Kaaba, you know, it doesn't have the kind of eternity that Muslims claim for it. But you could also say, if you're a Muslim, well, this is indicative of the sheer,
它是亚当用来建造神殿的原始石头之一。但还有一个传说称，亚当发现了它，并把它和伊斯玛仪（Ishmael）一路运送过来，这再次暗示最初的神殿可能在其他地方。还有人声称，伊本·祖拜尔曾将它放在一个约柜里，就像摩西用来在沙漠中运送律法的那种约柜。因此，故事的繁多本身或许暗示了一种感觉，即这个过程带有某种诡异感。但我也认为，显而易见，它们还暗示了一种敬畏感，即在作为对独一真神信仰象征的克尔白的力量面前的敬畏。所以如果你不是一个穆罕默德的信徒，如果你持怀疑态度，你可能会说，嗯，这表明克尔白，你知道的，它并不具备穆罕默德信徒所声称的那种永恒性。但如果你是一个穆罕默德的信徒，你也可以说，嗯，这恰恰说明了纯粹的、
the strangeness of this is indicative of the mystery. If what Muslims believe about the Kaaba is true, then of course it's strange strange because it's the strangest, weirdest, most potent, most holy structure anywhere on the face of earth. So what would you expect? All religions have strange elements. What would seem strange, unearthly elements to outsiders, wouldn't they? I mean, that's almost by definition because they're dealing with the realm, as you would say, of the supernatural. So if you are of a sceptical frame of mind, you know, you're not a Muslim, what do you think it is, it physically is, Tom? A stone cube made in the 7th century, basically, late 7th century?
这种诡异感表明了某种奥秘。如果穆罕默德信徒对克尔白的信仰是真的，那么它当然很诡异，因为它地球上面最诡异、最奇怪、最强大、最神圣的建筑。所以你还期望什么呢？所有宗教都有奇怪的元素。对于局外人来说，这难道不是看起来很奇怪、超自然的元素吗？我的意思是，这几乎是按定义来说的，因为他们处理的是你所谓的超自然领域。因此，如果你持怀疑态度，你知道的，你不是一个穆罕默德信徒，汤姆，你认为它实际上是什么？一个在7世纪建造的石头立方体，基本上，在7世纪末期？
Yeah, I think so. But I think also clearly there was a process of destruction in the wars that convulsed the caliphate. And where exactly the house of God that Ibn al-Zubayr identified, I don't know. I mean, it may have been Mecca or it may have been somewhere completely different. And the shrine that stands there now may have been established by Abd al-Malik. But we just don't know. I mean, there's no way of knowing.
是的，我想是的。但我认为很显然，在震撼哈里发国的战争中，也经历了一个破坏的过程。至于伊本·祖拜尔所确认的真主之屋究竟在什么地方，我不知道。我的意思是，它可能是麦加，也可能是完全不同的某个地方。现在耸立在那里的神殿可能是由阿卜杜勒·马利克建立的。但我们只是不知道。我的意思是，没有办法知道。
So basically, at the end of all this, you've left us none the wiser. I mean, that's the… I think wiser to the degree that if you are not a Muslim… Well, I think even if you are a Muslim, there's a strangeness to it and a weirdness to it that the sheer range of stories that are told about it hint at. think even if you are a muslim there's a strangeness to it and a weirdness to it that um you know the sheer range of stories that are told about it hint at if you're not a muslim then i think it perhaps complicates the history the traditional account it's a fascinating story isn't it i mean all this stuff about the early history of islam to an outsider to a non-muslim it is an absolutely
所以基本上，在这一切结束时，你并没有让我们变得更聪明。我的意思是，那是……我认为，如果不是穆罕默德的信徒的话，就会变得更聪明一点……嗯，我想即使你是穆罕默德的信徒，它也有一种诡异感和怪异感，围绕它的形形色色的传说暗示了这一点。我想即使你是穆罕默德的信徒，它也有一种诡异感和怪异感，嗯，你知道的，围绕它的形形色色的传说暗示了这一点。如果你不是穆罕默德的信徒，那么我想这或许让这段历史、传统说法变得更加复杂。这是一个引人入胜的故事，不是吗？我的意思是，所有关于伊斯兰教早期历史的事情，对于一个局外人、一个非穆罕默德信徒来说，绝对是一个
fascinating historical problem as we talked about when we did a podcast about the life of Muhammad, because there is so little that we know outside the Quran and the religious traditions. And there are so few other sources that we can use to cross-reference and all that sort of stuff. And it's complicated by the fact that it became identified so quickly with a kind of imperial ideology, I suppose. Is that fair, an imperial ideology?
引人入胜的历史难题，正如我们做关于穆罕默德生平的播客时所讨论的那样，因为除了《古兰经》和宗教传统之外，我们所知甚少。我们可以用来交叉比对的其他资料少之又少，诸如此类。而且，它由于如此迅速地与某种帝国意识形态结合在一起而变得更加复杂，我想。这样说公平吗，一种帝国意识形态？
I think so, yeah. I mean, Abdul Malik, I think in the episode of Muhammad, I said he's, in Christian terms, he's St. Paul and Constantine rolled into one, I think. And it's very difficult to get back beyond his reign to a sense of what might have been Mecca before his sort of possession of the holy places. And I think the 1920s, their control has been contested. There was the siege of the Great Mosque, wasn't there, in 1979,
我想是的，是的。我的意思是，阿卜杜勒·马利克，我想在穆罕默德那一集里我说过，用基督教的术语来说，他集保罗（St. Paul）和君士坦丁于一身，我想是的。要想超越他的统治，去体会在他占领圣地之前麦加可能是什么样子，这是非常困难的。而且我认为20世纪20年代，他们的控制权一直受到争夺。1979年不是发生了大清真寺围困事件吗，
when militants, Islamic militants who were fighting against the House of Saud took it over for, I think, a couple of weeks or something like that. But obviously it's a key part of their legitimacy, isn't it? That they control the holy places and they control the Kaaba. And they've actually knocked down a lot of the other kind of early Islamic buildings or pre-Islamic buildings, haven't they, to make hotels and things for people who want to go on the Hajj. I mean, we're never going to visit, are we?
当时与沙特家族作战的激进分子、伊斯兰激进分子占领了那里，我想有几周或类似的时间。但显然这是他们合法性的核心部分，不是吗？他们控制着圣地，他们控制着克尔白。为了给那些想要去朝觐的人建造酒店之类设施，他们实际上已经拆除了许多其他伊斯兰教早期或前伊斯兰时期的建筑，不是吗？我的意思是，我们永远不会去参观，对吧？
No. So that on-location walking tour, Tom, it's never going to visit it are we no so that on location walking tour tom it's not going to happen unless something radically changes in our own religious sensibilities um but it is you know it's it's it's such it's a fascinating fascinating uh question i think not just for people interested in early islam but more generally um how how how do historians from a tradition you know stand outside a given religious or mythological or spiritual tradition, how do they engage with it? So I wrote a book on this in The Shadow of the Sword,
没有。所以那场实地步行之旅，汤姆，永远不会去参观它，对吧，没有，所以那场实地步行之旅，汤姆，除非我们自身的宗教感发生根本性的改变，否则这是不可能发生的——但你知道的，它确实——这是一个非常非常引人入胜的问题，我认为不仅对那些对早期伊斯兰教感兴趣的人，而且更广泛地说，历史学家如何从一个传统出发（你知道的），跳出一个特定的宗教、神话或精神传统，他们如何与之打交道？所以我为此写了一本书《剑的阴影下》（In the Shadow of the Sword），
available from all good bookshops. Very good book. But one of the things that haunted me as I was writing that book, in which I came to feel more and more and more, was that any pretense I had that I was neutral, that I was objective, that I was objective wasn't the case because by not being a Muslim, that's not a position of objectivity and neutrality. That's a position as well. And if you stand outside it, how do you cope with it? And in a way, that's what kind of made me interested in the history of christianity as well um and more generally a sense that perhaps the very process of adopting a secular perspective alienates you from the very traditions that you're trying to write the history of if that makes sense
各大书店均有售。非常好的一本书。但在我写那本书的过程中，有一件事一直萦绕在我心头，让我越来越强烈地感觉到，我假装自己是中立的、客观的、客观的，其实并不是那么回事，因为不成为一个穆罕默德的信徒并不是一种客观和中立的立场。这也是一种立场。如果你置身事外，你该如何应对它？从某种意义上说，这也是让我对基督教历史产生兴趣的原因，嗯，更广泛地说，这种感觉是，也许采取世俗视角的整个过程，反而会使你与你正试图为其撰写历史的那些传统产生疏离，如果这说得通的话。
so tom what you've effectively done is you've plugged two books there shameless yeah so so you've taken a sacred subject and you've and you've ended with a plug for two of your own but do you not think i mean do you not think that is i think it's fascinating i think it's the i tom i think i mean we're not a historiography podcast by and large um but i think um uh it's a question it doesn't it's not just confined to studying religious history because i mean you're writing it writing about any subject you could be writing about 17th century england you could be writing about you know 1970s america i guess yeah 1970s america or indeed 1970s britain and you are you are trying you know you are you are trying you're pushing yourself um to enter the heads of people with completely different experiences from yours
所以，汤姆，你实际上做的是，你在那里植入了了两本书，太无耻了。是的，所以你拿了一个神圣的主题，然后你以宣传你自己的两本书结束。难道你不认为——难道你不认为那是——我认为这很迷人，汤姆，我认为——我的意思是，总的来说，我们不是一个史学播客，但我觉得，这是一个并不局限于研究宗教历史的问题，因为我的意思是，你在写任何主题时，你可以写17世纪的英国，你可以写19世纪70年代的美国，我想是的，19世纪70年代的美国，或者确实是19世纪70年代的英国，你正在努力（你知道的），你正在努力鞭策自己去进入那些有着与你完全不同经历的人的内心世界。
you're writing about ideologies and mindsets that are not your own and you i mean it's the question that we're always asked isn't it by at book festivals and at talks and things how do you be objective and of course the truth is you're never objective because you're always standing somewhere you're always looking for somewhere and you're always you you're always trapped in your own head but there's something it's kind of like to understand the butterfly you stick a pin through it it's that kind of slight problem that by doing that i mean you may be able to kind of dissect it and open it up and look at it but something's gone right um the very skeptical the skeptical mindset means that you don't get the mystery and you don't get the the beauty or the
你在书写那些不属于你自己的意识形态和心态，我的意思是，这也是我们在图书节、演讲和各种活动中经常被问到的问题，不是吗：你如何做到客观？当然，事实是你永远不可能客观，因为你总是站在某个地方，你总是在寻找某个地方，你总是被困在自己的大脑里。但这有点像是为了了解蝴蝶而把大头针穿过它，就是那种轻微的问题：通过这样做——我的意思是，你或许能够剖析它、打开它并观察它，但有些东西已经消失了。嗯，这种极其怀疑的心态意味着你无法领略其中的奥秘，你也无法领略其中的美丽或
the power of the vision i suppose is that is that right i guess something like that yeah something like that all right well i didn't expect this podcast to end on such a sort of metaphysical mood no uh with this is not uh you know this will never happen again will it tom i mean i apologize for that this didn't happen with the podcast that we recorded about the Costa Rican Civil War. Put it that way. No, it didn't. No, it did not. But this is a topic that is luminously holy to millions and millions of people.
这种愿景的力量，我想是这样吗？是这样的吗？我想差不多是这样，是的，差不多是这样。好吧，我没有想到这个播客会以如此形而上学的气氛结束。不，嗯，这不会——你知道的，这永远不会再发生了，对吧，汤姆？我的意思是，我对此感到抱歉，我们在录制关于哥斯达黎加内战的播客时可没有发生过这种事。这么说吧。是的，确实没有。不，确实没有。但这却是一个对千百万人来说具有发光般神圣意义的话题。
So I think it deserves that degree of acknowledgement. Excellent. Right. So we haven't solved the mystery, as as it were and we ended on a metaphysical note so everybody leaves with honor intact uh we will see you for more tom that was absolutely fascinating thank you well done but the next one will be less metaphysical okay that's jolly good so we will see you um tomorrow in fact for more world cup themed action. Bye-bye. Bye-bye.
所以我认为它值得这种程度的承认。太好了。好。所以我们并没有像那样解决这个谜团，而且我们以形而上学的调子结束了节目，所以每个人都保住了尊严。我们下期节目再见，汤姆，那真是太迷人了，谢谢，干得好。不过下一期会不那么形而上学，好吧，那真是太好了。所以我们明天见，实际上是为了更多世界杯主题的活动。拜拜。拜拜。
Thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes, early access, ad free listening and access to our chat community. Please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
感谢收听“一切皆历史”（The Rest Is History），获取精彩番外、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持“娱乐皆历史”（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、八卦猛料的固定栏目。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想享受无广告收听。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。